الدكتور وين أولاً بالنسبة لكثير من الأشخاص الذين
تعرفهم ، لقد سمعنا كلمة رعاية المسنين
ماذا تعني لأولئك منا الذين
لا يعرفون التعريف الدقيق
لما يفترض أن يفعله لك
ولعائلتك.  ما قد يعنيه ذلك
بطريقة مختلفة بالنسبة
للرئيس السابق هو أنه يتلقى شيئًا على سبيل
المثال بشكل مختلف عما قد يفعله الآخرون
منا بشكل جيد ،
لذا فإن Hospice Care
هو نوع متخصص من الرعاية الطبية
التي تركز على ضمان الراحة
وبالتالي فهي تركز  بشأن الحد من الألم الجسدي
وكذلك الاهتمام بالاحتياجات
النفسية لشخص ما ، والاحتياجات الروحية من خلال
فريق متعدد التخصصات من مقدمي الخدمات ،
لذا فإن الأشخاص المؤهلين بشكل عام
لرعاية المسنين هم الأشخاص الذين اقتربوا من
نهاية حياتهم وهم الأشخاص الذين يبلغ
متوسط ​​العمر المتوقع لديهم أقل من ستة أشهر
والأفراد أيضًا  لديك
حالة طبية غير قابلة للشفاء ، لا يتعلق الأمر
بالتخلي عن الرعاية الطبية ، بل بالأحرى
يميل الفرد إلى رعاية
مقدمي الرعاية
لأسرته ، وهو نوع من الرعاية أعتقد
أنه غير مستغل بشكل كبير ،
فهناك الكثير من الأشخاص المؤهلين للحصول
عليها  رعاية المسنين والذين من
المحتمل أن يستفيدوا منها وفي هذه
الحالة أنا متأكد من أنه كان
قرارًا صعبًا ولكنه مهم اتخذه
الرئيس السابق وعائلته
أريد أن أتحدث إليكم عن
مسألة شخصية وأتمنى أن تكونوا  حسنًا ، شاركنا
هذا معنا أه الدكتور وين والدتك
مصابة بالسرطان وقد تم إعطاؤها أيضًا
رعاية المسنين ما يدور في اتخاذ
القرار بأن هذا هو أفضل مسار
للعائلة وللشخص الذي
يعاني خلال هذا الوقت الصعب الذي
مرت به والدتي  سرطان الثدي النقيلي
كانت قد مرت بجولات متعددة من
العلاج الكيميائي والإشعاعي كانت في
حالة هدوء عدة مرات ولكن بعد ذلك
عادت مرة أخرى وقررت
في وقت ما أن هذا كان كافياً لدرجة
أنها لا تريد الخضوع لمزيد من
الجولات من العلاج الكيميائي أو  الإشعاع
والجراحة التي كان لها جميع أنواع
الآثار الجانبية وقررت أنها تريد
أن تعيش بقية حياتها بأكبر قدر ممكن من
السلام وبأقل قدر
ممكن من الألم وكان الأمر صعبًا للغاية على
عائلتنا كانت والدتي تبلغ من العمر 56 عامًا.  في
ذلك الوقت وكنا أنا وكذلك
أختي الصغيرة التي كانت في سن المراهقة ،
لذا كان
قرارًا صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة لأمي ، لكن في
نفس الوقت فهمنا أيضًا
أنها قاتلت لفترة طويلة وهي
أردنا شيئًا آخر علمنا أنه
لا يوجد علاج ممكن وأن أفضل
شيء بالنسبة لها لتحسين نوعية
حياتها للوقت المتبقي هو
رعاية المسنين وهذا النوع من الرعاية
معطّل للأشخاص المصابين بالخرف المتقدم
المصابين بالفشل الكلوي
المزمن  أمراض القلب والرئة
السرطانات الأخرى ومرة ​​أخرى هو شيء غير
مستغل حقًا لأن هناك
العديد من الدراسات التي أظهرت مدى
أهمية كيفية تحسين الجودة ،
وفي الواقع تشير بعض الدراسات إلى
أن رعاية المستشفى تزيد من
طول حياة الشخص في نهاية فترة
حياته.  الحياة ايضا